more now on Prince Harry and the Deluge
of claims and Revelations from his
forthcoming book spare joining me is
Grant Harold a former Butler for the
royal family uh thanks so much for for
joining me Grant uh I guess my first
question is uh the scale of the
revelations we've seen over the last 24
hours or so do you think they've crossed
a line sufficiently that your your
former bosses I understand you
specifically a butler uh for the then
Prince of Wales and Duchess of Cornwall
the now king and queen consort will they
be forced to comment and respond to some
of these uh these claims
foreign
never explained never complain and I
think the reality is the these
allegations are so serious I can't see
how the pilots won't want to say
something obviously it's difficult
because I imagine they will want to have
their own investigation again to look
into these uh allegations and but then
as far as what they can do this is
something people have been asking me
what what can they actually do to the
reality is there's very little because
we don't know I mean the writers we
don't know what is truth or what isn't
um but it's the whole thing's really sad
and it's not the family sent me that I
remember when I worked for them there
was there was none of this kind of thing
going on
um but again as far as what they can do
the only thing that's physically I think
that could be done or done to them is is
the removal of the titles and and we
shouldn't forget that is possible the
King has got the power to remove that
hrh from them if if the if it is see the
allegations are not founded to be true
then that is possible could happen but
the whole thing is just so sad I mean
indeed indeed it is I mean you mentioned
there when you were working for them you
didn't witness this sort of fractured
relationship just just let us know what
years you were Charles and Camilla's
Butler and did you see a very warm
relationship then between Charles and uh
and his son
between 2004 and 2011 and I'm lucky
enough still to live on on a Royal
Estate and from time to time see members
of the royal family in fact when a few
months ago I actually saw the the queen
concert and the king and and it's it's
it's difficult because when I walked
there they were very close family very
close family the boys the brothers the
boys got on really well best friends
practical jokers there was always humor
that was always fun
um with the father as well you know they
were they were a very close family and
when this all began when this when they
decided they were leaving the royal
family three years ago and and there was
all these kind of conflicting statements
which I'm sure we remember at the time I
kept saying oh there won't be anything
in it because they're close and of
course it's it's really strange me to
think that obviously there has been
these problems that have been going on
and it started to see this relationship
break down farmers do have follows
families do have relationships that
break down but it's just when you're the
most one of the most famous families in
the world it's basically it's not great
it really isn't great because
everybody's getting to see a very
different or here in a very different
royal family one of the the things
that's attracted attention over the last
24 hours was when Harry was informed
that his mother had passed away uh his
father now the king didn't hug him is
that something that that you can believe
was was reality but does it either way
imply the scale of love that the king
might have for his son was he a very
loving father regardless of whether he
showed physical love
yeah this is what I find really
difficult and it's difficult for me to
comment exactly because I obviously that
was a few before I was in the house told
um yes without kind of trying to break
competence they're a very close family
and and absolutely uh the king sure
would love to both his boys uh which I I
very much witnessed and
um the hugging thing you know I've seen
them obviously with any family you see
them hug that's not news at all as far
as what happened back then I I wasn't
there I I don't know what the situation
was like I don't know
um I don't quite know how that was dealt
with but the the family that I knew or
knew uh or can I say no uh I I love and
Kieran
um family so again as I'm I'm reading
the rest of the world what's coming out
and I am shocked at some of these um
these statements but as I said as far as
the truth part it's difficult to know
and I think this is what's going to be
really difficult for the pilots for them
to actually call men but at some point I
think they'll have to comment because
these are these are so serious I mean I
don't remember I think you agree and
certainly not in my lifetime something
as serious as this within the royal
family in fact that you could even go
back centuries
um where you have these kind of
allegations about brothers having fights
and hurting each other it's just it's
just unheard of within a modern Royal
Family do you think it's possible that
the king as an heir himself showed
favoritism to William uh as a fellow
Heir over Harry as a spare
I never witnessed that never witnessed
that the the relationship the love was
was always absolutely equal and as we
all know Harry when he was grown up had
um you know I I kind of a relatively can
I say normal uh up reading as normal as
it can be being a member of a family but
they were both boys were like to kind of
lead the lives they wanted make the
choices within reason that they wanted
and that was something that I witnessed
and I thought it was great that they had
that relationship but I I promise you
the the the love uh and everything was
done it was always from my view it was
always equally done so
um I'm assuming that what he's talking
about is very much since I've gone and
obviously the relationship sadly changed
especially in in recent years which I
find very sad because I just remember
the fun happy times and with the greater
respect I I thought about it last night
and I can't imagine what's going through
all of the heads uh the king the queen
concert Wyman Harding and I also but I I
miss uh Queen but I also thought I'm
glad that she's not around to see what
heart and Elliott has been spent 70
years creating suddenly
um I think this will damage it and
without question and it's bloody and for
me is how much it's going to be damaged
going forward